-Our next guest is
a four-time Super Bowl champion
and one of the greatest tight
ends to ever play the game.
He's partnering with FanDuel
for the Kick of Destiny
on Super Bowl Sunday.
Please welcome Rob Gronkowski.
-♪ One nation under a groove ♪
♪ Gettin' down just for
the Gronk of it ♪
♪ One nation,
Gronk on the move ♪
♪ Nothin' can stop us now ♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪ One nation under a groove ♪
-That's how you do it!
That's how you do it
right there!
Rob Gronkowski!
Gronk, it's always
great to see you, dude.
You're the best, man.
-Thank you, man.
-Come on.
You're always so fun.
They love you, too. Come on.
[ Crowd cheering ]
Big games yesterday.
You did a great job, by the way.
I saw you on --
-Oh, thank you, man.
-So, now it's set, though.
Super Bowl is set.
It is Eagles versus Chiefs.
What does Gronk
think about this?
-Oh, man.
Well, first off,
the Eagles kind of, you know,
got, like,
a free pass yesterday,
like, a get-out-of-jail card
for free.
Everything went
their way yesterday.
I was at the game.
I mean, I'm not saying
that they didn't deserve it.
They definitely dominated
the number-one defense
in the league.
And they dominated the Giants
before -- the week before.
I'm sorry.
I know we're in New York.
But -- And Kansas City --
they did enough.
They're always scrambling.
They always get the job done.
They definitely do.
You know, Patrick Mahomes always
rolling around the pocket.
Travis is always open.
They just get it done. They do.
And I would say Philadelphia
has been playing
more like a team
throughout the whole season.
I'm going to go with the Eagles.
Yes.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-Wait.
-Yeah.
-That totally changed right --
As you were saying it,
I was like, "Wait.
He's going non-Eagles.
You're going Chie--"
You're going with Eagles?
-Yes.
That's why I'm an analyst.
You know, I'm throwing you off
and then I go back there
and then I'm back there
and then, boom,
I hit you with the punch.
-You're perfect.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
-Yeah, I played against
the Chiefs many times.
And the Chiefs,
the last Super Bowl they won,
I was retired,
and now they're back
in the Super Bowl again,
and I'm retired again.
But when I wasn't retired,
we beat them every time
in the AFC championship game.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Wow!
-Or the Super Bowl.
So, I mean,
that's their formula.
I've just got to retire.
-You are a fun human being.
I love you playing on the field,
but, also, off the field,
you're always fun.
I read somewhere
that you said that you believe
your partying
made you a better player.
-Yeah. Yes. In ways.
So, I've always said that.
You know, it was kind of, like,
my past, the partying.
You know, everyone's like,
"Rob, you're partying too much"
or whatever.
I just had a good time
growing up.
I'm from Buffalo.
As you can see,
the Bills Mafia --
You watch -- The Bills Mafia --
they're tailgating.
They're jumping off RVs
into tables, breaking them.
-And breaking tables.
-That's how I grew up.
Like, I'm from Buffalo.
So, we love to have a good time.
We love to do crazy things
like that.
And then I realized -- Like,
I was telling everyone like,
"It makes me better if I party.
Like, I'm a better player
out on the field."
And then I realized it
and then I went back
and I was like, "How do I party?
Well, I'm carrying my friends,
you know, throughout the bar.
I'm holding them up.
I'm lifting them.
I'm curling them.
They're on my back.
I'm jumping up and down
and I'm dancing the whole time,"
Kind of like Austin Butler,
I'm gyrating like that.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yes, yes, yes.
And that's helping you --
-Yes. And then I realized
that that
translated to
the football field.
-Yeah, of course it does. Yeah.
-Yes.
-How close were you to
suiting up again this season?
-Um, I was, mm...kind of close.
-Really?
-Like, you know, I miss it
sometimes, but not really.
Then I missed it
for like an hour
and then I would go work out
and then I'd be like,
"Nah, I don't miss it.
I don't have the energy
to even work out."
And then, actually,
I had a couple phone calls
about like with six to seven
weeks left in the season,
and I took them serious.
I was like,
"Oh, what do you guys got?
Like, you know,
what's your offers?"
Like -- I was like, "Alright,
I'll get back to you."
And I took
a five-day period to see
if I really wanted to go back,
because, I mean,
I've been doing that
my whole life.
I've been an athlete
I've been playing football
my whole life.
So you can't pass on
that opportunity, you know?
I know, I mean,
I just played last year,
so I was like,
"Okay, I still got it.
I mean, I can if I really put
my mind to it."
And those five days passed,
and after the fifth day,
I was like, "I didn't even think
about going back once.
I ain't going back."
-Really?
-So I called them
and I was like,
"Thank you for the opportunity,"
the couple teams.
And I said, "Appreciate the
love, but I'm fine."
-So there were a
couple of teams trying to get --
-"I'm happy where I am.
I'm content where I am."
So -- And I'm still
very content with that call.
And I'm here now.
I wouldn't be here now if
I wasn't retired.
-Yeah, exactly.
We're happy you're here.
Yeah, we want you to be
here whenever you can.
[ Cheers and applause ]
We love you.
But I know Tom Brady --
you guys are good pals off
the field, as well.
Did Tom call you up
and be like,
"Hey, there's always
a spot here for you"?
-Yes. You know, I love Tom.
You know, he's a great guy.
He definitely always leaves
the door open, though.
That's for sure.
You know, "Buddy,
you know, "I support you.
I love you, man, babe,
you know?"
-That's how he talks?
-Yeah.
"I love the way
that you play, though.
You know you're
my favorite tight end.
Like, you can
come back anytime."
-Babe?
-"I support you big-time.
But you know I love
throwing you the ball,
so come back Week 12,
you know, or something."
-That's a pretty good Tom Brady
right there.
That's not bad.
-He definitely
supports you, though,
and he definitely,
you know, supports me
throughout the year
if I'm playing football
or I'm not playing football.
-He's a good guy.
-Yes. He's a great guy.
-I don't know if you saw -- he
does a great impression of you,
weirdly enough, speaking of --
Yeah, I'd like -- If you haven't
seen it, please watch.
-Dude, that was great.
That was perfect.
That was just what I needed.
I feel ripped now.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-You didn't say -- That's not --
You didn't say "dude" once.
-No, no.
-You haven't said "dude"
once on this show.
That's not a good impression.
-I mean, you know,
that's kind of, like,
my macho football, you know --
Gronk, macho football Gronk.
"Dude, throw me the ball!
I'm wide open."
-Yeah, yeah, yeah.
-But, yeah, you know,
Tom does a great impression.
Julian Edelman, though -- he
does even a better impression.
He does a great job at --
-Oh, we'll have to get
Edelman on it
and we'll get him to do that.
I want to mention your charity.
The Gronk Nation Youth
Foundation
does incredible work.
You're doing something
in Boston very soon.
Can you talk to me about that?
-Yes. So, the Gronk Nation
Youth Foundation --
we started about 10 years ago.
We're actually about to be on
the 10-year anniversary of it.
And, you know, I just had
an unbelievable
childhood growing up.
I had three older brothers,
one younger brother.
We lived in a great neighborhood
in the suburbs
of Buffalo, New York.
And I always had someone
to play with,
if it was my older brothers,
if it was
my older brothers' friends,
if it was my friends,
if it was my younger brother,
if it was my dad, if my mom.
It just didn't matter.
I had someone to play with
at all times.
So I wanted every kid
that I could touch
have that opportunity.
So I started the
Gronk Nation Youth Foundation,
and it gives kids that don't
have that opportunity,
like, if they don't have
equipment,
to go out and play football
or go play baseball.
We donate the equipment
to that organization then
so they have that opportunity to
go out and get better
and go out and have fun
and play sports
and do the right thing as a kid,
like the opportunity
that I had growing up.
-That's awesome.
And they're doing one in Boston.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Yes, yes.
So -- Oh, so -- Yes.
So, currently, the big thing
we're doing right now
is that there's
a playground on Esplanade.
That's where the land is.
And it's right on
the Charles River.
It's the prime spot in Boston.
There's a playground,
but we're taking it over
and we're building the
Gronk Playground right now.
It's gonna be done
next year in the summer.
And it's gonna be super-cool.
There's gonna be a 40-yard dash,
where the kids
can race each other.
And what's so neat
about it, too, is that
there's a football spiked
into the ground
and there's slides coming off
that football for the kids.
-[ Laughs ] Come on.
-Yes.
-See? You're getting involved.
I love that you're doing that.
Alright, so, I'm watching
the games yesterday
and I see this commercial
for FanDuel,
and it's like,
"Gronk, the Kick of Destiny,"
which is --
I go, "What is this?"
You're going to kick --
try to kick a field goal?
-I'm not going to try.
I'm going to kick a field goal.
Yes. Yes.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-I apologize.
-So, I'm teaming up
with FanDuel,
and the whole, entire project
is called Kick of Destiny
because it's basically
my destiny,
because if I don't make it,
I'm going to basically
get a beating
from everyone in America
that places a bet on
the Super Bowl game.
-So, what do you mean?
So, if you miss the kick,
then what happens?
-Oh, I'm not missing the kick.
I have no -- I can't miss.
-But have you ever kicked
a football before?
-Yes, I have
kicked a football before.
I've done Punt, Pass, and Kick
when I was a kid
and I actually made --
-How old were you?
-9. 9, 10 years old.
-So since 9 years old,
have you kicked a football?
-Yes, I kicked one field goal
in high school.
I was actually the guy that --
I was the kicker-offer in
high school.
I always -- I used my toe.
I just ran full speed to
the ball and kicked it,
and it went to
like 5-yard line every time.
But then we tried
one field goal, and I made it.
I'm 100% in my career
kicking field goals,
and it was a 33-yarder.
-Yeah, but that was high school.
-I know.
-Dude...
-Yes.
-Yes, it was high school.
-Dude...
-But this is for $10 million.
I have to make it for America,
and I'm going to make it.
-For America.
-Yes.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Yes.
-Well, I figured maybe
we'd try it out
and see what your kicking skills
are like with --
You ever play paper football?
-Yes.
Elementary school,
I never paid attention.
All I was doing was that
Tech Deck and paper football.
-Tech Deck, yeah.
-Yes.
And did you see me
kick that field goal
right when I walked out?
-Yeah, I didn't even know
what that thing was,
but you kicked it pretty far.
-That was an Ice Shaker.
It went right through.
-Was that the Ice Shaker
I gave you as a thank-you
for being on the show?
-No, that was --
[ Laughter ]
No, it was the one I gave you,
thanking you for letting me
come on the show.
-Oh, okay.
Thanks for kicking it.
I want to see what
your skills are right here.
This is the --
You've got to go through,
right through the posts
right there.
-Well, are you going to
hold it for me?
-I'd be honored.
-Did you do paper football
growing up?
-No.
-Oh.
-Did you play football
growing up?
-No. I tried out for
the football team
and I think I got mono.
-Oh.
-That is not funny, because I
had mono my sophomore year
in college
and missed three games.
Yeah, that's not funny, Jimmy.
-No, no, no.
I missed the whole season.
I'm sorry to get
into your head there. Yeah.
Now, what do I have to do
to do this?
What do we have to do?
-Alright.
You just hold it.
Just hold the top.
-Like that?
-Alright.
Alright. Oh, by the way,
I'm going to have that
single-bar face mask
when I kick that field goal.
Yeah. Like in the movies,
in like the 1980s?
-Yeah, yeah, yeah. I like that.
-Yes.
-Alright, here we go.
Gronk, this is it.
-This is for $10 million.
-No, no, this isn't it.
-Oh, alright.
Yeah, yeah, yeah. Not yet.
[ Drumroll ]
Oh!
-All right, no. You missed it.
Gronk, no, we'll try it again.
Here we go.
Look.
No, no, we've got it again.
That's what we do.
Alright, here we go.
I'm setting it up right here.
Hold on. Is that right?
-Right there, yeah.
-Alright, go, buddy.
Yes!
[ Cheers and applause ]
It's good! It's good!
Rob Gronkowski, everybody!
Check out his Kick of Destiny
live during
the Super Bowl broadcast.
We'll be right back with a
performance from Tyler Hubbard!
Stick around.
That's how you do it, bud.